et action
blaster go blaster papa Lester go blaster
je m'appelle Peter Dinklage et PI joue
Eddie Plant
alias le fire blaster qui est le fire blaster c'est
mon surnom les petits pains au sucre
Peter Dinklage juste honnêtement terrassé,
il a apporté la plante Thunder Eddie est
leur ennemi d'enfance en particulier à
Adams  brûleur de personnage comment vas-tu Eddie
sup deuxième place a un ego assez gros
bonjour Big Apple la cavalerie est arrivée
si vite parce que c'est le seul
personnage qui va vraiment rester coincé
dans le temps il est totalement tubulaire il a un
mulet géant
il a des tatouages ​​pas le beau
les tatouages ​​qui sont branchés de nos jours, j'ai appris
à les aimer
boum c'est ma confiture, il a aussi l'habitude d'
enlever les manches de tout ce qu'il
porte Eddie les plantes, c'est tellement
oh tu viens d'avoir une merde enflammée